talking about the weather forecast
certainly windy last night still a
little bit breezy this morning
some areas too john still hanging onto a
little bit of wind most areas have
calmed down though
for the early morning hours but don't
let that fool you the wind is going to
be back
so we're looking right there on sunset
road right there near the galleria
and the winds is it's whipping so let's
get to your forecast i'm just going to
use my trash can as an example for your
tuesday winds
once we get those winds going back in
the morning we're looking at 10 to 25
through the morning hours but by noon
15 to 30 and gusts 40 maybe 40 to 50
for the afternoon and evening hours so
we are looking at a lot of wind that's
going to blow trash around
i just turn off your sprinklers if
today's your watering day don't waste
the water
and secure lightweight patio furniture
because these winds are going to come
back in a pretty big hurry
we've got a mix of 40s and some 50s
around the valley this morning
20s up at kyle canyon so here are your
headlines cooler mid 60s today
with those gusty west southwest winds
midweek
tomorrow into thursday we're looking at
highs only in the friday
only in the friday boy i'm already there
aren't i with highs only in the 50s
chance of showers tomorrow and even
thursday and friday
with mountain snow and then we're back
to 60s and 70s for your weekend as we
spring forward into daylight saving time
so we have wind advisories for central
southern clark county and eastern clark
county
where it starts at 10 o'clock goes all
the way to 10 p.m northwest arizona
as well as southeast california i think
we'll have mostly sunny skies but there
are some clouds around us that may snake
sneak in this is the core low that's
going to bring us the chance of rain and
mountain snow
and then again some clouds at times so
we'll just see a mix today for sure
let's talk about heavy rain let's jump
out to the hawaiian islands
the island of maui has seen over a foot
of rain
they've had some homes that have been
damaged by flooding and they're
expecting a dam
to maybe break there on the road to hana
so they're evacuating some homeowners
and
some residents there i mean this has
been some very heavy rain still rain in
the forecast
unusually heavy i mean you know showers
daily tropical showers
that's not unusual but this has been
crazy rain for the island of maui
all right let's get to our forecast we
are looking at sun this morning
some clouds mid 60s and a lot of wind
for your tuesday
still maybe a little breezy tomorrow 40
chance of showers tomorrow
then very low snow levels thursday and
friday mornings down to 3000 feet with
those cooler 50s
morning lows in the 30s and low 40s so
we may see some snowflakes out on the
west valley we'll see
don't expect it to stick though and then
a nice weekend as we spring forward
with daylight saving time in effect
we'll lose an hour of sleep but i love
that 71 on sunday